so part one he deals with arguments part
two he deals with negotiation and then
part three he deals with the sacrifice
in his three-part series uh the
arguments uh section's the longest one
is his argument's four while I get
married because people want to partner
it makes lots of references to biblical
terms lots and lots of references in the
first 45 minutes to uh biblical
standards but I don't see Society
um and men and women being held to said
biblical standards the way that they
were originally intended for my
understanding anyway
um he argues that marriage is the death
of sex or can be the death of sex but he
also says singlehood can also be the
death of sex which I'm not sure I agree
with or even understand why he would say
that because
there's no single guys that are spinning
plates with lots of women in tow going
how do I get one of my plates or my
girlfriend to have sex with me this is
exclusively a search term that Google
has organized with men searching for how
do I get my work you know my wife to
bang me how do I get my wife to sleep
with me how do I like single guys aren't
aren't doing that so I'm not really sure
why he's suggesting that singlehood is
the death of sex but maybe maybe he
means in the term of like
promiscuity or you know potentials that
come with that
um he goes on to say the highest
mountain to climb is looking for
marriage as a lifelong date fair enough
you know if you're going to get married
you're basically going to date your wife
for the rest of your life so you know
there's there's a reason why you know
he's saying that I made a funny note
here with quote end quote he says uh
open quote you need something to do it
might as well be that uh close quote and
he's you know referring to getting
married like you have nothing else
better to do in your time you need
something to do so getting married
should be you know your number one
priority
um
he discourages impulsive Hedonism he
uses hookers and cocaine as an example
as a life strategy uh and I agree Chase
Excellence not women I'm not really
aside from uh
Hunter Biden maybe I mean I don't know a
lot of people that uh Chase impulsive
Hedonism you know using his examples but
okay
um
he also seems to think that shackling
yourself to somebody is a great idea to
hold yourself accountable in life
now actually I should back up a little
bit because from what I know about him
he's only had three prior relationships
to Tammy Tammy's his wife I think
they've been married for 33 years if I'm
not mistaken but it's over 30 years
and he Pine for her when they lived in
the same neighborhood in Alberta if I'm
not mistaken I might even been across
the street it might be butchering the OG
story I'm sure somebody in the comments
will correct me but that's my
understanding now
look uh
he doesn't have a big Notch count
neither does she obviously because
they've been together for so damn long I
think he's how old is he now let me just
quickly check here
uh
how old is Jordan
he is 60. he's been married for 33 years
so in his mid to late 20s call it 26 27.
um yeah okay so Tammy obviously had some
other relationships prior to him but it
doesn't sound like either one of them
from my understandings racked up a large
Notch count so that's possibly one of
the reasons why they've managed to form
a reasonably healthy monogamous pair
bond to one another is because you know
we've seen these charts you know I've
talked about these charts many many
times if you're dealing with a woman and
she's had a lot of Partners throughout
her life and she loses her virginity
younger in life she's a bad long-term
marriage partner the chances of getting
divorced I think there's something like
double after nine Partners
um and it continues to go up from there
I mean the data really stops after I
think something like 12 or 13 is where
they stopped it but it seems like both
of them have reasonably you know low
Notch camps which which would you know
point to one of the reasons why they've
been able to deal with one another for
so long actually one of the points I
made on my first page over here
in part three at minute 12 second 20
he's crying you know how Jordan Peterson
cries you know from time to time in
interviews because he gets choked up
over something that really hits him hard
that's close to home
well it became clear to me that either
Tammy had cheated on him at one point or
somebody very very close to him had
cheated got cheated on by his woman
because he was going on a little bit of
a tirade and then he got all choked up
and started tearing up man the Water
Works started to come on so again he
didn't overtly state it but it became
very very clear that it either happened
in his relationship or somebody very
very close to him maybe a brother
um brother-in-law somebody very very
close friend
um but he did that uh you know well up
with tears so that was I thought that
was interesting because he because he
spends a lot of time arguing for trying
to fix things even if she betrays you in
the marriage
um
he talks about overpopulation which I
thought was interesting which I agreed
with I
he provides a good argument for children
uh I'm not anti-children you know by the
way I'm just anti-living in a way that
looks like married I'm not Auntie
dealing with women I have an LTR I'm not
Auntie having kids I have a child
um those things can be great if you set
yourself up properly
um and I agree with them I don't think
the world's overpopulated I don't think
we're overpopulating the world that's
just some [ __ ] that they you know
that they uh you know the weirdos
try to sell today
um
just to just to keep you in check you
know they only want the dumb people
reproducing because they vote for more
more in big government you know how it
goes
um so we deal with the overpopulation
note spends a lot of time talking about
your responsibility chasing Hedonism
okay well Hedonism and irresponsibility
was mentioned quite a few times because
I've got to mentioned in my notes
throughout all these here
calls men that do that uh pathetic night
so this is quote he calls men that don't
get married and just date pathetic
nihilistic 40 year old Frat Boys So
gents if you're out there and 40 plus
and you haven't gotten married yet
you're a pathetic nihilistic 40 year old
frat boy
so man up and get
um now
one of the things that he's selling a
lot of in the second part is children
children it's the best possible
relationship he says they will always
have the they always want the best
possible relationship with you
but he completely forgets to tell you
that that ends into teen years
teenagers don't care about their parents
um they care about their friends they
care about their social network they
care about their peers they care about
their sports team their extracurriculars
then they care about their parents maybe
um but the teen years aren't great years
for most parents in fact I've had
conversations with a few guys and you
know the topic came up
um you know in the past was like you
know is it worth having kids and you ask
a guy that's got a six-year-old he'll
say yeah you ask a guy that's got a 16
year old teenager or teenagers he'll say
no almost always so he's not being fully
transparent with the kind of [ __ ] that
you're going to deal with when you bring
kids into the world yeah they're great
and yeah you know your legacy and blah
blah blah and your name passes on a DNA
sort of thing but let's be honest it's
not rainbows and butterflies and they
don't always want the best possible
relationship with you is what I've seen
anyway and you know the conversations
that I've had and this is you know
speaking as a guy that has a kid
entering teen years too now
um very surface level
again you know dispersion of people that
avoid marriage and kills calls them
quote Scoundrels and half-wits end quote
man there's a lot of there's a lot of
disparaging terms foolish juvenile
short-sighted hedonistic nihilistic
cynical Psychopathic impulsive
promiscuous pathetic nihilistic 40 year
old Frat Boys and Scoundrels and
half-wits I've never heard so many
disparaging
lyrics used for guys that don't want to
March into the slaughterhouse of
marriage and wife up them women
women
um
we're not going to talk about that we
already talked about ownership
Manning up mentioned several times oh
one of the things he also mentioned
because he likes to go on about
promiscuity
um he says we just about took ourselves
out with AIDS now
some of you watching this may not even
know what AIDS is but
I think in the 80s maybe even early 90s
I think it was mostly 80s
they scared the living [ __ ] out of the
population the same way that they did
with the beer bug you know
this is going to end up killing you and
it and it ended up killing you know some
people not that many I wonder how many
people died from AIDS let me just see
here how many people have died from
uh beginning of the epidemic it's quite
a lot actually
um
84 million which isn't even close to
wiping us out but
sorry 33.6 million 84 million were
infected so they're saying 33.6 to 40.1
okay
fair enough
but again again it's a little bit blown
up you know you know wipe yourselves out
but that was uh something they scared
the [ __ ] out of the population within
the 80s and it it didn't come close to
wiping anybody out really it just took
out a few uh
Shady players I'd say
um at the 22.56 Mark in his argument
section
he says
you can't just love a woman you need to
stand up so to the argument of why can't
you just get into a long-term
relationship or date and not get married
because that's because that's always
what
um you know a lot of people say is we
don't need to get married to
um or throw a party to prove our love
you know we love each other you know
with one another word blah blah blah but
his argument is you can't just claim to
love a woman you need to stand up in
front of your whole community and bind
yourself to that commitment then he says
in quotes or are you just above all of
that are you right or you are just above
all of that are you end quote so again
there's a lot of shaming language just
get married don't be a [ __ ] you know
you have to stand up in front of your
whole community and make that commitment
or are you above all of that says Kermit
the Frog I can't do his voice because I
can't I can't do that pitch
um if you can't sacrifice with a
ceremony then you then you should just
ask yourself just how committed are you
just as a person or yourself he calls
men that don't get married shallow
again there's no reference or any talk
whatsoever about risk mitigation the
horrible state of family law
how women behave in divorce and how they
take advantage of family law
I'll cover those sections of my book in
just a little second hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out